знаєш цю кількість депутатів дісталося іп
дзвенить і шок і вона продовжить і нога 1000
блокаду криму там досвід і серйозного немає
нею демонструє настрій громадян у
адміністрації президента новації з
гордістю називають інструментом
електронної демократії у team ви знають
вас популяції під час голосування але і
довелося і тут культурно побачили де id
російські там ініціативи рахунок до
дискредитації там як історія про дарта
вейдера ми побачила і де ці політики
скупого волосся вибух ми знав йти на 1
голос так та так тут тоді в нас пан
кивалів забираючи голос і за 5 центів за
свої витрати а б проголосувати це
просити за вишиті та не банківської
карткою та ідентифікаційний номер ми ви
вирішили задком його верифікації
дтп на міша голосувати та розміщувати
патетики громадян України з промовою
складні і трохи анонімність я навіть ями
під крісло душу майонез перехідних
персональних даних
ловко на владу the span у кота і daddy
і вечір закінчується і особняка та діалогу та
у нас функції електронних по 3 однак
china буду влада пара квадрату вигляд
побачилися за багато відомства на Еньші
ще буду робота на приклад президента
США по 5 а направлена ​​на його ім'я
струмує змін до законодавства до явно
знаходиться в юрисдикції Верховної Ради
україни чевенгуре пара спрямовувати і вин
буде про направляючих pt чиюсь все-таки
формати руку на контролі всі механізми
вище подрібнюється видно законом
процедурними громадянами
електрон не плутається і малак за проти
ти у всіх органах кладовище та на паркінг
десерт не піти мені поспішай і
сценічні адміністрації чи то кабмін свої
онлайн-платформи геть і так і на вигляд
крила